you also appeared in now
what is one of the biggest films of all
time uh spider-man no way home
everyone loves it everyone loves
spiderman yeah well i was i went to see
in the cinema and when you guys appeared
the cheer was amazing uh yeah um can you
solve the cinema
you know you went to sleep it was so
cool yeah i mean it's so you know i i
finished playing i'm i'm far too old to
be playing spider-man now but they they
asked me back and and it's the sweetest
thing ever
um because i put that to bed i was like
no that's i'm good i'm done that's
that's lovely um and tom holland is just
the best so i just kind of became a fan
again and then and then they asked me to
do it and and toby was doing it as well
i have it's toby's i'm i've got to do if
toby's doing it
and at least you're at the oldest
exactly
but he's my but he's my spider-man so
it's like you know i i would practice
his lines in the mirror when i was at
drama school like i was very high at the
time
my friend terry mcginnis who and he
would he would crack up and he would
look at me like yeah you'll never play
spider-man andy and uh and then and then
here we are and uh
but me and me and toby we um we became
friends and we
we snuck in
to a theater in los angeles um
on the opening weekend and we were just
two you know middle-aged white guys and
baseball hats and masks and we just kind
of
absorbed the most yeah you know special
special things in the middle of a
pandemic and it's one of those things i
mean when you've had a big success in a
role like that
going back to it did it feel like a high
risk thing to do yeah it was a stupid
idea it was a really really scary thing
to attempt yeah especially just the
costume
38 year old man in a spandex unit they
are unforgiving those questions
intimidating very intimidating
[Music]
you